SPEAKER: This video describes
how you can create navigation
buttons for your KML.
You can view KML in geobrowsers,
such as Google Earth and Maps.
Using navigation
buttons in your KML
allows you to guide your
users through your content
in a meaningful sequential way.
To create these buttons, first,
create or acquire graphics
for the buttons themselves.
Make sure they are an
appropriate size such as 75
by 20 pixels.
They should be JPEG,
GIF, or PNG format.
Next code the HTML for
each of your placemark
balloons and embed this HTML
within the description element
in your KML.
Consider using tables to
format the text and graphics.
Be sure all HTML out appears
within the CDATA element.
You'll need to give
each of your placemarks
an ID so you can reference them.
Do this by using ID equals
X in each placemark tag.
Note that your IDs must
start with a letter.
In the embedded HTML,
use an a href tag
with each navigation image.
But instead of a standard
URL, use balloonFlyto
to point to another placemark.
As an example the code shown
here points to the A placemark.
Use these links to create
a succession of placemarks
in your KML.
In the initial and
final placemark balloon,
you can omit one
of these buttons.
To see additional compelling
examples of KML in action,
visit the KML gallery at
earth.google.com/gallery.
To learn more about KML, visit
code.google.com/apis/kml.